[Musique]
il aura fallu 500 millions d'années pour
dévoiler au grand public sécher d'oeuvre
de l'évolution
parce qu'avant ils ont dû être nettoyés
et recollés dans les coulisses du Musée
royal de l'Ontario
et quelques années plus tôt extraits à
coups de marteau des Rocheuses
il y a un demi milliards d'années ces
créatures étranges sont apparues dans un
tourbillon de créativité un monde
sous-marin enseveli par des coulis
debout
c'est un des chapitres les plus
extravagants de l'histoire de la vie
[Musique]
on a l'impression qu'ils veulent démolir
les montagnes une roche à la fois
mais Jean-Bernard Caron et ses complices
n'ont pas été condamnés aux travaux
forcés au contraire moi quand je
travaille ici c'est une relaxation en
fait
j'ai la liberté de pouvoir étudier les
fossiles les plus importants de l'époque
cambrienne de nos origines de l'origine
de la vie
les fossiles de burgès racontent une
histoire fantastique mais méconnue bien
avant les dinosaures quand les
continents étaient encore déserts
il y a un demi milliards d'années au
fond des mers l'évolution fait un bon
gear les premiers prédateurs
apparaissent les proies inventent des
façons de s'enfuir de se protéger et de
voir ce qui les entourent
une course aux armements qui donne
naissance aux ancêtres de presque tous
les animaux actuels
mais leur corps est mou sans eau ni
dents leurs traces ont disparu depuis
longtemps sauf ici
sont un endroit magique et ses roches
sont légendaires
les roches de ces montagnes se sont
celles qui s'étaient accumulées au fond
de la mer à l'époque
très peu de sites dans le monde avec ce
type de préservation et c'est un trésor
vraiment unique c'est découverte ont une
importance pour toutes l'histoire de la
vie c'est pas juste pour nous au Canada
les gestes de Bergès sont répartis dans
les parcs Yoro et kutney en
Colombie-Britannique l'accès est limité
aux chercheurs aux étudiants et aux
bénévoles que Jean-Bernard Caron a
choisi
pour avoir une passion pour pouvoir
venir ici une motivation très importante
puisque récolter ses fossiles ça demande
beaucoup de travail et d'efforts
physiques allez on va faire ça
ce qui nourrit cette passion ce sont les
fossiles qu'on trouve
je pense qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
choses en dessous on s'attend trouver
des choses de très belles choses
on a le petit moment de silence quoi
on casse la roche et on se dit ouh là là
est-ce qu'il va y avoir quelque chose
est-ce qu'il y aura quelque chose ou pas
et au moment où ça ouvre là c'est le
il y a la dimension scientifique et la
dimension personnelle il y a l'agrément
le fossile peut simplement
vous chacun ici à sa spécialité son
animal favori
[Musique]
Jean-Bernard Caron s'intéresse en
particulier à un tout petit poisson
metase prix
c'est l'ancêtre de tous les vertébrés
des grenouilles aux girafes en passant
par les humains
OK
et quand on ouvre la roche la première
chose qu'on voit ce sont les yeux
ça étincelle dans la roche on a
l'impression qu'il ne demande
d'en prendre soin
et l'équipe va en prendre soin les
fossiles sont catalogués et bien
emballés parce que le trajet est long
jusqu'à Toronto
[Musique]
une fois au Musée royal de l'Ontario les
fossiles sont déballés en ordre
chronologique c'est comme revivre l'été
pendant toute l'année chaque fois qu'on
déballe un nouveau fossile c'est souvent
une redécouverte puisque des fossiles
qui n'apparaissaient pas sur les dalles
qui étaient sales ou couvert par un peu
debout se découvre sous l'eau s'aperçoit
il y avait quelque chose d'autre là on
n'avait pas vu sur le terrain pour les
yeux qui sont préservés ici
on ne trouve pas toujours un animal
complet souvent ce sont les pièces d'un
casse-tête et le meilleur exemple étant
vedette dans la nouvelle galerie du
musée
le premier celui qui nous a posé des
problèmes c'est c'est
qu'on appelle la Mona Lisa ici de notre
collection une Mona Lisa dont il n'y
avait pas seulement le sourire de
mystérieux pendant plus de 100 ans cet
animal il était connu plutôt sur par des
morceaux comme celui-ci là les pince il
pensait à l'époque que c'était le corps
d'une écrevisse et que la tête manquait
le reste du corps il avait été décrit
comme une concombre de mer et puis la
bouche qui était là avait été décrit
comme une méduse en découvrant un
fossile complet les crevisses le
concombre de mer et la méduse sont
devenus une créature féroce de presque
un mètre de long
le premier prédateur de l'histoire le
premier animal à avoir des yeux la
vision à l'époque ne permet pas de
former une image mais plutôt de détecter
des mouvements
c'est une innovation clé autant pour les
prédateurs que les proies règle générale
quand les yeux sont au sommet de la tête
c'est que l'animal vit au fond de l'eau
mais ici on dirait que tout est permis
il est facile de la faune
désorganismes qui sont un peu loufoques
avec des animaux et un certain ici qui
s'appelle opabilla avec 5 yeux une
espèce de trompe à l'avant qui ensemble
un éléphant alors que c'est un
arthropode un organisme qui se relie aux
écrevisses donc c'est quelque chose de
très bizarre
ces créatures ont été ensevelis côte à
côte par des coulis debout comme un
Pompéi de l'évolution
ce sont les personnages de même chapitre
mais pour comprendre leur histoire il
faut récolter d'autres indices
dans les Rocheuses la routine reprend
pour les chasseurs de fossiles je pense
que l'équipe aime bien se réveiller avec
l'odeur du café aussi
bonjour Mélina
l'été dernier Jean-Bernard Caron et son
équipe exploitaient un nouveau site sur
lequel ils font des biens désespoir et
ils n'ont pas été déçus on vient
d'ouvrir un bon de fossiles ici avec un
bébé tokumia un arthropodes très très
joli
très bien préservé de la tête à la queue
le déjeuner on a trouvé
deux fossiles de prédateurs du Cambrien
c'est deux fois aussi qui sont
exceptionnels très très rares il y en a
un ici et un là on voit la bouche qui
est ici avec les appendices et puis là
c'est la carapace qui recouvre sa tête
ces plaques permettent de plonger dans
l'histoire du Cambrien parce qu'on ne
voit pas seulement des personnages
isolés mais leurs interactions des
scènes de la vie quotidienne qui se sont
ajoutées aux collections du musée
le grand déballage
[Musique]
en regardant quels animaux sont présents
et combien il y en a on peut recréer
l'écosystème où il vivait et même
imaginez leur comportement en
particulier celui de nos ancêtres des
poissons qui comme ceux d'aujourd'hui
vivaient en groupe si on a des
assemblages comme celui-ci avec beaucoup
d'espèces différentes ça c'est une
nouvelle espèce il va falloir qu'on
décrive et puis là il y a un petit
assemblage de poissons métastoguina et
donc à l'époque nos ancêtres n'avaient
pas de mâchoire c'était des poissons
et puis on était vraiment entouré de
grands prédateurs donc on y a chez
PayPal mais peut-être que quand ce
groupe on a pu échapper à nos prédateurs
prédateurs et proies étaient cachés dans
la roche depuis 500 millions d'années
pour les voir il faut être en plein
soleil la lumière accentue les
contrastes
[Musique]
c'est comme si il posait pour la caméra
à l'époque la mer couvrait une partie de
l'Amérique du Nord mais ce n'était pas
les mêmes espèces qui vivaient près des
côtes ou dans les eaux plus profondes
une première coulée de bout les ans
ensevelie les survivants ce sont
multipliés et d'autres espèces sont
apparues chaque fois des coulées debout
les ont ensevelis les différentes
couches permet donc de retracer
l'histoire de chaque site à condition de
retrouver les indices aujourd'hui
accrocher à flanc de montagne
ces roches ont 500 millions d'années
mais la formation des Rocheuses remonte
à peine à 100 millions d'années et même
moins ces roches qui s'étaient déposés
au fond de l'eau ont donc été pliés et
comprimés si on veut pour devenir des
montagnes
les chistes de burgès c'est un
casse-tête vieux de 8 milliards d'années
dont les pièces sont éparpillées dans un
paysage plus grand que nature
nous en tant que personne on est
vraiment tout petit on regarde les
fossiles ils sont tellement plus vieux
que nous on regarde les paysages qui
sont tellement juste les gens
n'oublieraient même pas là-dedans enfin
c'est à toutes les échelles qu'on est
comme des petites fourmis en fait on a
juste commencé à gratter la surface de
ces montagnes même si le travail peut
sembler répétitif la passion se
renouvelle avec chaque découverte
ce soir c'est la dernière journée pour
la première phase de l'expédition
on a fait beaucoup de très grandes
découvertes scientifiques donc
félicitations à tous vous avez tous très
bien travaillé
tant que je pourrais je continuerai à
faire ces récoltes de fossiles
c'est eux la source de nos histoires
leur travail permet à des créatures
muettes depuis 500 millions d'années de
raconter le rôle qu'elles ont joué dans
l'histoire de la vie sur Terre